joe starts us off in boston hi
joe joe how are you good hi dave hikers
how are you
better than we deserve man what's up hey
uh
thanks for taking the call i'm actually
uh in the process of uh
getting ready for retirement i'm age 16
my wife's 59 and we're in the last five
years
and we're we're actually in the process
of downsizing homes and we're going to
split
homes between florida where we just
purchased a home for cash
and downsizing our home in massachusetts
and buying a smaller retirement home
then we're going to snowbird
between the two houses and the way we're
doing this is we're actually
having a house built in a retirement
community up here
that's going to close in march and our
current house that we're in
probably will not be closing until june
and so we've got this little bit of a
gap period where the equity in the house
that we're currently in will not be
available to be put towards
the new house so when we finish this we
won't have any mortgages whatsoever and
i'm trying to figure out
whether i should take a mortgage on the
new house which i'd be paying off a very
short period of time
or using another sort of debt um
instrument like a home equity line of
credit
or or something else that might help us
bridge for those two or three months
yeah since you're going to pay it off
very very fast you don't want any
closing costs right
correct and a home equity loan will
allow you to do that
okay yeah no closing costs and uh you
know a fixed rate
and no balloons on that home equity loan
in case this drags out further than you
think it's going to
but you're just going to get a home
equity loan it's a little scary
um i wish you should line this up in a
little different order but uh
uh but because sometimes these things
don't work out like we think they're
going to so you need to be
financially and emotionally prepared to
own both these houses for a while if
that happens
yeah and and we we're we're actually
blessing them in the position we can do
that if that happens
so we're so what do you have other cases
you have other cash laying around
uh yeah we have about 350 in cash
sitting around total net worth of about
4.8 million
where's the rest of the money uh 1.6
million
taxable 350 of its cash versus stocks
how much is that how much is the beach
house
how much are you short by not selling
your house how much you're going to
borrow
uh so we'd be borrowing probably about
300. just take that out of the 1.6 it's
not this
it's not in a retirement account and
just take those
just take it as a taxable transaction
yeah but you should not i mean
absolutely shouldn't shouldn't be a ton
of taxes on it
because it's not in a retirement account
what taxes would be on it just the
increase in capital gain
capital gains yeah yeah yeah i'd take
enough to just pay it off
i do that in a heartbeat there's not a
chance with a 4.8 million dollar net
worth i'm borrowing
money to buy my beach house no i mean
there's
not a chance you just use some of your
money that's what it's for
yeah and yeah it may cost you a little
bit of capital gains money but
you know what you can do just look at
the most tax efficient way to do it
in other words what pro which pieces of
this and
these investments do you have that have
the highest basis versus their current
value
so minimize your capital gains because
you you cash out the thing with the
least
yeah and i think you can get some tax
advice on that to walk you through it
you can probably do it yourself you
sound like obviously you're
you're very sharp yeah but no i'm not
gonna tell you borrow money when you've
got a 4.8 million dollars
a million six available to you that's
not even in retirement accounts
nope nope and you know dave you brought
up the whole thing about timing
it's crucial i remember working with an
entertainer
years ago that had a home in la and
another home was going to close and they
got this short-term financing
for two weeks and guess what it took two
months for this thing to go through
so what i would tell everybody is just
slow down
slow way down look at it do it with a
clear conscience do it the right way
and as you said dave expect it to take
longer than you think
yeah because it's going to well and and
that that that's what i would do in your
situation joe
but uh obviously you're you're not a
dumb guy i mean you got 4.8 million
dollars dumb people don't usually do
that so
um i met a few but not many and so uh i
think you're gonna do fine but that's
what i would do if i woke up in your
shoes
and uh you know i'm in the
in a situation where my net worth is
greater than that and there's not a
chance i would borrow money when i've
got taxable even if i'm going to pay
some taxes on it
i'm going to do that rather than borrow
money because of course i don't borrow
money periods well that's what it is
you're allergic to it i couldn't do it
i couldn't do it well it's just not an
option it's not even on the table
yeah and so here's the other thing that
i run into and it won't happen to joe
because he's not he's at a different
level but sometimes
when people get in these situations
where the house
i was talking to a friend of mine just
the other day this happened he um
he closed on his new house and the other
house was supposed to close two weeks
later
the old house well the buyer gets all
jerkified and starts you know every
nitpicking little ridiculous thing
and because he put himself over a barrel
he ended up having to bow down to
ridiculous
buyer requests at the last minute and
even
even escrowing money and possible price
cuts and other stuff because he was
stuck he put himself where he
had no walk-away power when he could
have told that buyer to pound sand
that's right and get 63 other buyers in
line because it ain't like nashville
real estate's hard to sell
right that's right but when you've got
your other house closed and you got the
money for a short term he's over a
barrel
all of a sudden that buyer's got him by
the throat yep sure and can misbehave
all over the place now i don't think joe
would allow that to happen but
but this guy and this guy didn't he
stood up and he just said no
you guys are going to do it the right
way or we're going to drop this whole
thing i'll start again
but what if he'd run his buyer off
because the buyer was misbehaving
now he's got to start again and what was
supposed to be a two-week deal
like you said end up being a two month
or sometimes a two year because
sometimes
things like pandemics come up
right in the middle of your best laid
plans right yeah yeah
no so yeah bill you know that's the
thing you put yourself in a
in his case too not in joe's case both
cases
the guys had the money but they just
you know how it is when you've
emotionally sold the house but then the
guy it starts being a twerp
and you're like man i either got to
start this whole process over with a new
buyer or i got to put up with
you know okay i'll do this thing yeah
okay i'll do that thing
and all of a sudden you're just getting
you're getting jerked around
because you put yourself in a position
emotionally in
nate and maybe financially for some
people oh yes but you're just like
but i think you'd be going nope i'm done
that walk away power is imperative yeah
change smart it really is
it changes everything it just changes
the flavor of the deal
changes the way the thing goes down if
you're dealing in strength and you can
be calm
and kind and gentle uh but and but firm
yeah you don't have to get run over but
if you're like man i remove my furniture
you know i remove my wife in stuff's on
the truck
and now we and now this guy's you know
pulling our chain
and if you didn't know oh buyers are
sometimes
crazy yes i do know
some of you people that are buyers are
sometimes crazy